the first tutorial rigoletto no equal
understand what you know how it works
basically johann is a place concept
softic who an to many die simple things
and training tutorial big thing is what
many cases you can use for learning and
results for computer vision ms
bettina wedi his network  from the sketch a
prepaid backbone and it may well
considered way so the psalms new tool
center court of peace like note to self
because i'm losing jupiter lab at the
speaker of the house of the self
scanning today to the family of the porsches
and ferraris talk about  you can follow
up with that you have done that the
internet is not great for health
inspection sex we hope you can set up
und google talk google cola google
notebook according to googles cloud internet
so this is what we're going to talk
about the world cups  on the basics and the
basics of machine learning
tänzers autograph amazing adventures alexander
mohr concept car data sets data loader
the template transformed into  a huge
amount of that have lots of the
different things
nobody at todtnau recognizes it
said apple client bn tv offheim i wanna
do you can get some free stuff interview
service is great cherry and events
speech that is out world racing the
first great day they  ever create some
very big player executed creative
director of swatch
cooler here should a flax in porto cervo
function argument xvid market price
expert results meanwhile went that is necessary
you can use it bagger in pouch and the
people like some people have you spencer
flottbek until the tree  of life changing
the execution mode that will if so if
there was like you can use this amazing a
year if the excavator is here but
never the special teams on board plugin to
be back to anything is that who the
bit hippie look at the block  has indeed
terrifically lucrative banking built
xliv zloty lowered
this staff the domain giant celebration
liked so much like it hot house jazz
thing about it l  ike it's going python
rzb back to you can do it cluster
switching ffs interfaces simple
interface chemmedia understand the thing
about as complete a history of the great
depression
the worst case of the dance floor is big
one and it's great if you want you back
to basics  of terms of service great der
herr tänzer flott transformers google
product the slots on moment ins great
things about the dynamic light weight
watchers the give you like a great
interface delicious highlevel interface for
the burning love you just get started
relaxes kz is unfortunately very preferences
twitter  -feed of direct attach poultry
des nice you get loud plane
favorite place on features will be a
library switches location so available for
like gate between will work the
computer vision part of the same vortex
inforadio
the gentlemen cool cars is like the fast
and special thanks in  the capital values
stanford an automatic documentation
of purchase great day afloat on
specimens be more re  nnen here at the
conference he was too slow to win
is always good
[music]
justice network ngn looks like you we
have to network so dies standard imports
in port of spain because you need some
to important and the team at work
package model of the functional
interface which is very easy nature of the
nn
and actually parameters in more unfortunately
last on a simple network just to
get a feeling that what you can do you
have the essence sequential
sequential is basically just released
roddick osterbrink of players layers
like we just what it because  the bet
wins you take you know häfele which is
called confronted with one in the channel21
channel and girls of five half a
july could see the layer that is
exactly blockbusters the words generally
hewlett-packard into the way to go to
cars for this point of the things  that i
want you back a bit more complicated
model like what remains you in men's
motto if it works with the clarinet
super lucky k  places
construction of japan class if we do this
thing here we have a bunch of
lawyers paysafe remember the girls of
glass if you have to define award
function and function basically get some
data in use case accent passes the data
extruder complete review
if you now on  output in the new here
you can choose to find your data flow
through you can fly away is it there
maybe you know how crazy the
whistle yes you can you can get to the airport
such a basic dancer who is
following is ok kurt a caricatured
questions problems  fast but to get
hold of him we have nothing to offer because it
belongs to basics ngf basic import like
streaming service support of summer
import from matt/limmat north wedding
monitor is of course had to be the best
thing about this and that ends ozawa
must be exact purple cancer center houston
amt  windows now so in ampere you can
you can create the identity metrics pnp
we can say what you get
tänzer soll interfaces is
you  can am great lake random access
memory
the pricing and p
michael kerres kay one value uk vector
which is like a bunch of view the way
trip to the people left a
dancing general station on the you
can have likes again people before the
people 24 people can  for the pag
schneider not even website
looks like the weekend you can everybody
david
that the band of numbers insam
kaindorf shakes fidget of the ex here of the
main krines morgana is okay of the ex take that
question is it like a melody of the
people it said
yes  yes
thank you for medical care people ok
to recognize who interfaces in numbers
icann news metrics modification here
again ex transport times multiplex des
is possible for something new something
you can't say what
hier ist nordic capital die hier ist
small team that transport and suppliers
of the match for the collectors edition
things like most of the operations lag i
can say that for excel installed or
elsewhere in place ope  ration says martina
blaha elsewhere in place operation
[music
] is great because it is like crazy
broadcasting tricks like you can make
wie broadcast it you can access also
looks like the very first element up
here by doing this thing we can get it
works to  the extent that thing in the
preview version before it is none limited
by now it's almost there is a very very
nice ping is a traffic light system and day
you do some great wheel to convert from the country
ancestry.de
[music]
when the squeeze sofa
operations services colt auto grad in
georgia lake worth it so here we create
tänzer double you would operation
to holland america safe one minute off
of cancer patients with computation the
glass walls this is my car is the the
optimal costs like and mary hughes
trained interface of change  for
contact manager media center you can do
calculation allocation but context
don't track that if you have some cars
if the jusos join context managers
import before
special cars convertible have you want
to record breaking abstract how violent
the latencies australian circuit
tutorials online in the lodge of the man
they used the rebirth of thought you
don't need another huge sensation so
what do you have to execute
the algorithms  networks you can do
anything that used to be you think about
how many core courses tatort tänzer
course but now motto magic ran fast
speed up session do you need to install
q/q the nn crew.cc the enzer is yes but
do conde a star  .de encoder in salt
lake city -star jeff green energy was
still the giants 22 there you still have
time
usecon da ins goal todd cleaned library
samuel anaconda peña osterfest aware
that if you work with it in some and any
thing but
shortly before  you there before enormous deep
insights michael jackson would have sven you have lots
of the model dort kuga in the ju
basically moved to you by now have to
device and i don't have to make the dfl
statement jugendme  ister big bang well
what landscape is it you know sales
operations schott would have our gpu in the
home cinema or moving day to the future
the head and smart fortwo passion if
the return becomes a you can trust
tested an cmk sense to move computation
keeper toño automatic transmission and
very simple linear regression with
whip optimizer and the center world
http at the workshops
so here you think you are you can use
orders may he have before and create a
data and well thought you very simple
wandering people and unfortunately sub-people
output discussion
gpu-z viola  small north end position of
half duet you can do it like you can
have live data parallel season dancing
stage no dealer fish a second
up to the bumper of music labels
complete overkill content of the motto
supermassive parameters i would
now put it in the port switches  when a
one in four dimensions and have one car
three people
the moscow ring demands function and
function  now data tied to our very
very boeing
here here here you can
automatically like about the move the
wanted about the will here the costs
according to 1a rostock waves documentation the
dog strings ok center line crash motto
our gp3 series the witches brew dog
model optimizer model  los optimal
system model das ist los angels sing
party to device with my model to the eu
and of course of a wide variety of cars
have your say that the winner is so
custom that this and i have a day after
the flag bowl of them  for the much going
to give you a combination with that used
to explain who in the nn motto you have
the bunch of laws it here a using the
mean square terror social problems
help model mai los meine
optimal meitinger training lugano
grab
a move right way of  the model to keep
you because the model hess parameter
center parameter will study the ps
or the optimist and internet data and
model parameters down to the fli  ght data
our gpu and shader and astrid kretzer
in discos enke the message of the
operations and gets gpu data rescue days
the bodywork is naive youtube is in
for some reason your device is a
trekking grade autobahn my work station
goes to spend my way flap changed
that  in the factory in the zib2
ok ok optimus functional training
lucentis is when we there really like
about watching you can you save it takes
over here you have to do it yourself
already on 1 as soon as you drive of may be
one of the things you have to set  the
model entertainment and you have the
mood for example drop out is only
available light active in the train your
network and then you like the way back
and one on the west ring gotha warmuth die
hafen baufenster baby don't forget that
the red dragons on the automated
updates support software either earlier
model and get some predictions and here
in the thread interested in split trainings
et variations has here the school desk of the
data down here the  validation data
in the after watching the data systems
so here you can save our view
instead of doing stretching
this was here the orchestra great
interested party a booklet parameters opti
motto europes michael path of the
pyramid on the motto one to optimize
laid off that might cause differences  of
the model and very very nice decreases
the lost thing 1 107 96 500 50 runners
will be available will be at have more
machine learning for one in depth
notebook will be once to show you but if
you want to do everything from scratch
here is in files here  is machine
learning for one with the soul or
caught in search of lots of duty
animation center line regression model
and works agency iha optimizer you have
to ride your training ludwig heidi
behind bars don peppers or jude law
and order made the tears of course you
be  there for you thought i'd heard you
can can you can you can you modifying
training costs fuel
die back in the best of five friends only
the bag  ger for the fans that is
no statements
now escalated so rudas print leyen
debugging here you can apple
brivio a finca story fine scale for
problem credits print and destroy of
course and assessment of the case is
making of users have you here you like
what is over the  people who do you like
playing on two legs of low zero from
hesse is the bagger pdb or ip db
bite the bagger barry handy i would have
a user and often play that you really
improve the internet is basically here
an import trace function function here
and tracing  here in my function
kansas luck something flexible text
max heinzer one chain values of this
is how you really need that if you need
some more context where are you need to
do some of magic computings that die
bagger and you can do it in new networks
switch  modul sanchez tyson gay parade on
data access and creating what you again
in harriets by nn mordio eveline
lemke on cars immediately wrong passports some day
to day to  day in your function at the
triesting soon on the first longer you
sf lotte people relatively
quick putin in discos 1 no
that was five teams triathlete here the
tri teams once they should get off the
search max schubert five dances
shape five police officers wanted
match  race an excavator is here locally max
that was the expected from the ex
the car is so execute nextel a ok
media can you get the locals that here is
an elvis molex here capital 6 4 6
then tested geneva execute the office
of course we have some of  which allows
us to build tv networks
yes for most the same speed
world is at its performance
engines home performance compared to fix
and end of low end of low computer
slaves can do like a bunch of
automation as well as much much faster than
any speed mxn  etfs in some nice results
were they make some time so much faster
if dancers afloat
yes than pink so what about memory
consumption think its stance of the
pants on sale back for good  ist tänzer
flow is even further and feel like
about what if you have it tänzer vom
modeln junior grafites find you can
write this page is much more dynamic and
you can have random numbers interview
hat supermodel
who is nicole tonic switches from
microsoft and facebook
basically  this format forex trading
computational graf new networks for kate
and then you can work it works of simple
cases export york topmodel café tänzer
flow to what ever closer stuff is
happening waf matmour and the label ok
basics dating chalk look couple of tricks is
ready on the left  data
interested transforming and ride for
mit hot pursuit vegf trap eye square
park lakers is the first date class of
the transformers and transformers and
talking about james holmes war computer
vision remains dominant at the moment stuff
you have the data loader a sampler
is a new feature on  super talent
[music]
so what they just simple great ribbon
interface on different can the corset
the core developer can be different in the m
days at sea to get one element of days
at quotes
elvis dogs and cats days at here my
holding baic roding data from the box
camp sample template is still big lots
download it looks like at the paybox in
kiev  sample folder which contains train
and wait and to classics auctions much
as i mentioned that they have no one's
for you have to implement functions and
you just the things that i would appear
to files
12.06 vienna
the youcat alpin daisy implemented a ghetto image
size and here  the label is such a network
of image and how do you see david
bowie have to implement remains open
if necessary help or combine
function duel you can get
defendant catalyst on the classic
africas is ochs dictionary with schnapps
from the place took two the for you have
this week the  list of images and
corresponding class combine
drinks with you don't have to bed and
here's looking at the images
thanks
as in  as close as hefte we can get
date of computer vision half of the
formula 1 celebrates that are kilo
images that once ballots many computer
vision junior band take that before exempel
maybe you want to the top of your image
yeah that's really the way it is here in  club of
the height of you don't wanna do one
transform what you want to do malte
dort transforms so here is doing horizonte
flip sometimes you can easily
implement
transform functions now really
simpel interface and then you start
implement a method once coach robert
is when  ends there should from youtube
composite transforms so maybe you first
one flip a rotation away and
sometimes it that makes sense to the
flag jasper to compose your image
argumentation pipeline a floating
kafkaesque auto offer statement
action at the limited im wald you can't
do  you like it offers you limited
limited like it says pen options
ottawa and you can just do it you can't
wait to half the grand chero  kee
finished sometimes nied herring compost
function witches getty images and offers
lot of bees
josef random koller tweets traffic light use
your network general this time saw later
and do the development like herr
verband of transformation it here
because like all dancers android so normally
should data  normal network ngmn the
star of the standard value bet purchase for
the nation and now you don't get much
anymore both dancers okay the image and
people at bruce buchanan the plug-in
tuifly crazy transforms into crazy stuff
image documentarist rebic the a nice
tutorials and  imagination and
transformations in the eastern part of the city
imitation kilo scm it has become an extremely simple
operation and in the
player import or instore kilo sms
sms sms with fastbreaks bikes hang on the
gable complain about merkel oslo fun for the
first time because the internet
of google just like the search  for
image argumentations so the lord
maybe research gorbachev
strategies for how to do  image
argumentations general guisan chef coach
implementation that means before the
google project recipe management you can
use the trade organization waited for
him too much
data one concept to get data to get one
day point of you want to get the edge of
data and torture cover the  city jet set
in can return patches of fate automatic
data processing so with my idea
manager at daiwa leica is guided in the
panel yes now there is basically what
do you create a data loader youth days
at we know a lot of thunderstorms at send
you can say you  want to shuffle data
interchange edi make sense was at the
national that could have there we can
against amber of workers as side two for
you can get any trade office training
data loader of the cortex function that
urgently
if you're in the transformers the  data
loader expectations and day the set the
return tokyo im it right but mine
transforms the transform cent so
regiodata transforms create data loader
parameters i want that works co denn
hier ist get that ended consists of cool
images two people soll color and the
size of two three four plasma the
witcher 2
mein label switching speculation that
sums to you know you can get one image
we can get a bunch  of images the edge of
images to the data loader like
transformers and transformers dorf but
sometimes you want to have more
controller builds how you get the date of
strategy for you get me you want the
dogs and cats in relation to catch the
[music]
random  samplers samples the sampler
stage series knows about crew it is
super simple interfaces implemented
and return net index of what you want to
take that
basically return christoph in the
starting this last from angry birds yes
we here is an example before the sampler
have to implement a ita function  and
here we go generate returns leica per
mutation of the seas no details don't
make me i have to implement a function
and you get the hell you want  to have we
have transforms transforming the data
access to the simple data loader
combining orders may dugard bachelors
of data processing of sampler is remote
control about how it simple very nice to
have problems at the prima schleck
implements oldies class is for myself
and youtube
[music  ]
there the best practice for schools
in transformers is normal that at
yamaha teams from the compost industrial
production dancer flow hot tamina des colt end of
low transformers means from et do like
crazy transformation pipeline switcher
the part of computational count when the
weather is super me thinks that is  maybe
you're motivation first very nice ok
borders however so i thought that we
have always concert as well as
dancing datacenters transformers fans so trends
for learning e learning basically hughes
network systems network is going to be
free trade and image net data said the
new president  network e health claim
which is responsible for like crazy
features in d  em recording from the
classic super duke of this way you are
only have to train
which is just a few parameters are the
management rastatter passe
metzger but standard imports when
thorsten pütsch imports basically
we're going to the pin codes and the
final table of content  with happy to view
the data model los optimizer training
the machine so dogs and cats data
set before a candle in the previous
notebook like head of the window control
center harrislee praised the difference from
over variations data said they don't
really augmentor data mining flipping
sant  joan armatrading transform and mary
dacian transform if a going to
import dogs and cats
[music]
workers and the same before the nation data
loader jet aviation day special forces
for workers are we have a data model like
nicolas like the masters in the
u14 category  as well as know user per
trade network and watch offers a bunch
of free trade networks for example
alexis neiers crisis teams net inceptio  n
the punch inc the credit suisse
boss brady after new express next inception
[music]
bpm-suite train to you can
you can set against the automatic
download he is from herbert about new
juve network weekend as if award for
1000 m class security measures to  date
cars if you're just print model is the
skin looks like
that is necessary network is all i have
the great eight we see as well as one
besides the essen two hundred something
like it offers more we find the
interesting bad is headis line these
fully  connected ligna layer in the
developers on input features and tip
on 1000 individual switch
correspondent class is what we have to
do parameters ask quiet cars to
the means we were calculated credit
suisse of the mainstream update of the
world of trance training at the häfler
herpers for example  the train the
trainer otto premingers model which you
have great train parameters from which
takes it all trouble witches mit rosen
rosen
which a  re used court open
and here is using the fashion week
freesort parameters the make sure that a
moll op
yes we can a frieze whatever works the
nexans good at freezers were interviews
were always you can start was lars von
trier ask the turning the gun
preacher robert  mohr in the progressive
trade it for you could have three weeks
back learning and very end features ok
we have the model of a parameter of the law
firm nieding barth as a guest replays
last before the contacts player will
want the look before you want yuan lines
layer2 on impotent attached cleaning lady
express.com cat oil has when here and
there a man brings uwe kaa gent ok and
checking out of rosenheim among other things the costs
only unfortunately is still out there with the ford
escort model of the space creating motto
because i'm going to create mode
unfortunately that's it  combine function with
six active the motto life replace why
with funny los angeles in this case you
smile optimizer if here trainer am
model par  ameters function and only want
to optimize parameter switch and trade
girlfriend on most fans be
it the slightest trains for two rocks
and hear this is your phone flat
wrong people in front of lucas glover the
eeebox a model trade overweight
raining data loader fans of the day the
day  the model told that allows you to
back will pascal or optimizer kelkheim
statistics dieter now imports
tyler the gentleman 200 here prima chastain
just for the evaluation should now with
1000 meters
the band creates the goods on guard
here is still from some of the
big fashion  train
[music]
who said the word pretty much better now you
can't do urban think there are some
leibnitz which would help you tube
samples of the tnt express shot
the victim metrics with out that's the name of the
skate supermodels before goes yes
somehow optimizer hands you can
create is super white trainer which
matching motto patrick's day to
calculate that you can trainer and
interests completed  together
and then you can say that didn't write
and ride of function here training
leads saturday
[music]
no
tu
hello it would have logged your father always has
that we're
ok
[music]
if he is the internet yes that
would it be too berties on board is it at
google with visuals yes training and
competition models award and the iss on
board axway gateway interface training
here a model training always my
trainer in mainz and in korbach cell ag
find out what ever im interested in
tomb raider  in a then in the ka news
all dancers flew goodness be full
kensy times my training percy margraf
isolation icon histogram great for the
car neither with dancers vx 1 1
unthinkable interfaces new zealand origins
of low interface
who is out
baku is the system further people from
facebook research economic
situation pictures of what's that you can have no rangers interested
gentlemen how the news are now at the
ventoux that collecting from
j  so mr. hopp now from here to
tweet on the internet lukas is there is a
lot make the new day network and stuff
is just released and change will change
of service is even longer
a dancer float man later the bath
beyond the production of trade coffee
tea in the  posse tory coffee to go into
production service system so the onyx would have
the going to tweet onyx
people to export models in the otto fleck
it competency
mr univ old with short spot on
street in european research
that was now started then eurostor high
level  stp from the dancefloor what a delight
Mr. van essen stephan hackert rumor
has it is made for research and things
you can do it blog post
[music]
the app is implementation of early
stopping function at potash one a
hitherto recognized member interface
thinking of the early stopping  the very
easy to implement high level match also
fast discovery tools
[applause]